hey everybody Chris here a lot of people
have been asking how do you give art
direction to designers how do you do it
in a way that empowers them to make the
changes that you want how do you do in a
way that doesn't mean that you're
sitting on the box moving the mouse
around yourself because the important
part of art direction is to keep people
feedback so they can grow as designers
and you can get the work done and focus
on other things and on this episode
we're going to work on an editorial
spread for a new business idea that
we're going to be launching more about
that later but you want to see how we do
it
come with me alright let's check out
your labs so I want to just take a
moment to explain to people who are
watching what's going on
mint is helping me out with designing a
new newspaper for one of our initiatives
right now we're just playing around with
the title thirst and so that's the
masthead and so we'll look at some of
the typography she's been working on
this for some time so we got a lot of
layout to look at all right so let's
take a take a look at the relay out here
this is a very clean layout you're using
future right there
I like feature it's part of the identity
we've been using it's really nice a nice
clean layout good use of like a bold
headline subhead and body copy and a
byline right there what I don't love
right now is the way the thirst is in
there it's kind of about an angle and
it's not quite working for me okay let's
take a look at your next one oh wow okay
this one's really nice I love the way
that you cut off the t's on the
lowercase Futura typeset and I like the
eye the way you cut that off and it
matches nicely with the cap height the
thing I don't love is the way the S is
chopped up at the bottom it look feels
like there's a flat spot there but
things that are working really well are
we got a nice table of contents set up
here great kind of bold numeral there
and I like that and when you're doing
some modern layouts like this I don't
think you want to Center your type I
much prefer a justified left type and so
if you do that I think this is going to
look a lot better I don't love this
little bit over lapping this because I
think it's gonna be hard to read but it
doesn't need to be overlapping there so
I would just pull that down there
and lastly I see a couple things here
there's something that looks like a
legal copy down at the bottom which is
okay to be centered because you don't
want people to look at that but then you
have this really bold separator between
the legal and the bottom which doesn't
make sense to me they could work much
better if you took away this black line
and maybe use the black line to separate
like this is the content of the magazine
and this is legal so that'll give you a
little bit more room you can move this
down but it's also funny to have white
space trapped underneath like that not
necessary okay let's check out the next
layout
oh okay this one's really nice just
simple clean this one has less
information on it but I like now how you
have a much bigger point size of Futura
overlapping than that this is this is a
really clean layout feels very modern to
me and feels very fresh so well done on
this one I guess this is page three I
like this one all right ooh I like this
a lot too
now it's not centered but it's cut off
to the side and I really like things
that bleed off the edge now that may
present itself to be a problem for us
when we go to print because it costs a
little bit more to have things bleed but
I like that a lot that's a good layout
if we were just doing purely digital it
would be not an issue at all I'm
noticing that you have a double line
here when you have a thick line and a
thin line it tends to read a little bit
more old-fashioned okay so if you wanted
to make it look old-fashioned that's
fine I think there's an issue with
spacing maybe it's a little too tight
together so if it's a little farther
apart bounce it like five points down it
might feel a little different and less
old-fashioned and there's other things
that you can do like you can do vertical
separators to help tie it in and then it
might make it look a little less
old-fashioned a little more modern here
I don't love the way that you have the
headline bleeding into the photo I don't
think that's a great usage of that I
think when you have just a big headline
it's great to overlap something like
this it doesn't really add a lot so we
would probably crop this photo a little
higher I noticed a drop cap here and
that's like a really old-fashioned thing
to do so when you're doing a modern
layout like this it feels really out of
place
so I would bounce that okay let's keep
going ooh well okay this is a page five
I really like this layout a lot
beautiful
use of type negative space colors and
I'd like that you push the type to the
edge there that's really nice that's a
modern thing to do some suggestions here
perhaps these two point sizes are way
too big for this and you want to create
that kind of big type little type and
then let everything else breathe we
don't want to compete with all that
space so and it could solve another
problem too you have this little photo
thing that's a placeholder for something
and it doesn't tie into anything in the
layout and it's important for your eye
to have things to inker around so photo
probably could tie together with this
copy this copy were a lot smaller like
50 60 percent of the size and line up
the left edge right there and I think
this will look really great this will be
a problem but we'll solve that but if
you did that this layout would look much
better one other idea here is to maybe
take this yellow and do an over print so
you see the photograph underneath bleed
into it like overlapping I think that
could look really smart and then leave
this here I also noticed that using the
strong kind of process color language
that we've established for the TV or our
YouTube show and it's nice to have here
but I don't think it's necessary like
you can easily get rid of that and it
would be just as strong okay one of my
more favorite layouts very well done
next one this one's a little awkward to
me you're using up all the space and the
shapes there isn't a great rhythm in
terms of how you're using it and I think
this would be much stronger if you
didn't use center type Center type again
is very old-fashioned it works if it's a
strong display and you have too much
stuff going on which is probably why I
think you did this but it would be
better if you just set it from left edge
to right edge since you're already using
a full bleed layout and just make it run
in there and then space the let the
words the way you want okay just like
leave it in a text box and then let it
flow the boxes themselves need to be
worked out a little bit better and I
think this is one of those cases where
you need to really understand
figure-ground ambiguity and let things
kind of move forward or backwards in
space right now very clearly there's a
hierarchy of the stacking order of blue
black pink and then the yellows on top
of that and then the whites on top of
that what would be nice is if some of
this type were blue so the blue is
overlapping the pink the pink was
overlapping the yell
the yellow and the white and that's how
you create figure-ground ambiguity so
even a very flat two-dimensional space
you can create a lot of dimension that
way so you haven't shown me any of these
layouts
how come okay we'll move on that thank
you for that answer that was a wonderful
answer okay because you were still
working it out and you didn't want to
show me something progress right totally
understand
it's a designer's dilemma people don't
want to show you stuff unless they feel
like they've totally resolved it which
is totally ok all right now min is using
a very modern layout and grid system
very beautiful design but she's using a
very kind of old-fashioned serif
typeface this is some kind of thing that
looks like but don't need to me but very
condensed do you remember what the
typeface is no no okay that's fine so
this is one of those things where it's
quite unexpected right where you're
doing a very modern layout and you
pushing things around but you're using a
classic Sarah face so I have similar
problems with it I won't repeat myself
too much here but the overlapping is
kind of important maybe this one is okay
because the font is quite big but here's
where I think there's an opportunity
that you missed where you have this
little red thing now it's important to
tie your elements together to repeat
elements and it shows harmony and
cohesion so this red dot here ties this
but there's nothing important happening
on this axis right so it's better to
take this red dot and probably tie it
right here strong vertical alignment
with the photo credit with this line so
it snaps it's great I mean you did a
little red dot here I think it would
really anchor these elements together
but otherwise a nice layout okay this
one's a little kind of avant-garde
you're kind of using halftone patterns
boxes on top so I assume this gray area
would be a photo but maybe this is just
white some very modern things working
here I believe if you just used maybe a
sans-serif typeface for the rest of this
save this serif typeface for the Masset
I think it would look a lot better okay
and maybe have these patterns not be
stuck in a box I think it wants to be a
little bit more free-floating and and
kind of have an organic shape to it I
think that'd look a lot better the one
thing that sticks out to me there's two
things actually that aren't working for
you is this little red line which
doesn't seem to tie-in
anything on here okay so it's a little
arbitrary we want to use those graphic
elements to tie things together the
second thing is the thinness of this
font also matches the stroke weight of
this box so look in here it almost looks
like this red is right next to the eye
but then it's underneath so there's a
lot of weird tangency is happening here
it's a font where a bolder sans-serif
typeface instead of a serif typeface I
think you would have a little bit more
forgive a wiggle room or forgiveness in
the layout okay let's take a look at
your next one so there now you've
changed it to a SAN serif typeface but
it's also very condensed and thin and so
we had these kind of weird repeating
things look at the weird space you look
inside the C there so there's a little
white space kind of trapped in there and
you want to avoid that okay so
typography is really about understanding
overall layout making information read
but getting all the details right so I'm
gonna use my pen here to point this up
little white triangle trapped in there
you see that right there
little things like that that's what you
kind of have to keep pushing and pulling
until you get to all those things to
work in harmony let's look at the next
one okay that's an unusual typeface
that's kind of interesting probably not
right for us it feels like it's gonna
get old really fast okay but I like that
you tried that again you're using the
drop cap now you've added the yellow box
around it I do like the idea of using
yellow because it looks like it's
highlighting something and so you can
use that in elsewhere to use them as a
design motif okay let's keep going all
right now this one's really funky we're
using serif sans serif italicize lower
case a lot of like things going on in
here and I think because of that we got
to keep this layout a lot simpler okay
and maybe or you go really crazy with
this it's kind of stuck in the middle
with a lot of design you don't want to
be stuck in the middle you want to be on
the extreme on like the avant-garde
postmodern expressive typography or on
the other side which is like really
Swiss modern we're very clean this is
somewhere in the middle and I like the
exploration here but perhaps this font
isn't helping you right now I think
you're using is that univer so univer I
think
I like univer it's very flexible it's
almost but it has almost like no
personality to it and I like something
that's got a little bit more personality
using a font like accidents grotesque
Helvetica or something else even
Victoria would look better and so one
thing I want to talk to you a little bit
about is maybe activating this space
here so I'm gonna show you so I'm gonna
sketch Eric you want to get in the
camera here alright so the way I'm gonna
sketch this is look at this zero zero
one the way that I wouldn't do this is
to do something like this okay we have
that box what I would do is lower the
baseline of the 0 1 so that parts of it
get cut off and I'm going to
deliberately draw this so that it's a
little rounder and a little bit more
square in proportion so it's we're not
gonna use univer okay and what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna let it bleed off at the
bottom here and then I'm gonna do the
slash a slash would look like this
so now imagine all of this as the yellow
of color right here this is all yellow
and the where we see the white we can
see the photograph underneath which will
add some dimensionality to the layout
I'm not calling the rest but you get the
idea so this would be the photo here
you see so it's going to activate the
space underneath it and then we can use
this serif typeface as a contrast to the
sans-serif over here and like let it
bleed through I'm not doing a great job
of drawing this letter form but
hopefully you guys that are watching on
YouTube get the idea
now the other thing that you want to do
is treat the layout as a
three-dimensional thing had this ban of
color wrap around the other side and I
think you would look really smart
somewhere over here so we want to repeat
the dimension something over here so
it'll feel like it's a ribbon next
circuit going around the backside of the
page and coming back on this side and
then you have all your other typography
wherever it may exist and letting it
bleed through or overlap so that could
be one of your layouts okay make sense
all right let's look at the next one
okay I'm not in love with this layout
and you think there's a lot of issues
going on with it
whenever we're designing a layout we
don't want to cut off the whole page but
we don't want to use things that fill up
the whole space because it just makes
the page smaller and smaller and so what
it winds up doing is it creates three
separate things like this space this
space and this typography on top so we
want to get away from that okay so
something like this it's much better if
you were to break up this black box and
maybe inset it so let me let me do a
quick sketch about what that might look
like alright so here's the page what you
don't want to do is just cut it off like
that so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
Incept the box so let's say something
like that okay and instead of running it
all the way up and down because then it
trapped excuse me it traps this space
and this face which isn't necessary
great thing to do let's cut it off here
I like to do it a little bit more than
half way and we like to repeat elements
okay so this element repeats up here so
that dimension is being repeated then we
can put the business design journal
something like that then where you have
the zero zero one summer 2016 I would
look at doing the same thing there zero
zero one summer slash 2016 and add that
little graphic in there and then the
rest of your copy which looks good
you okay and then you could leave this
space open so you see now this activates
the whole page I'm not cutting anything
off and now I put in some really big
type in here it's gonna look good you
can even try doing something where you
you put the baseline and the cap height
and you bite them together so you
tighten the letting I'm gonna try that
and see how it looks keeping what's a
here in here and we have three lines of
copy so I divide the space into thirds
one two and just line across just so I
have some guides here and the way you've
designed it maybe it's like this so
there's my tea maybe it was my age now
I'm going to bump like as if we ran in a
space here and just continued a line
over here I and our
okay and I don't like leaving just one
letter at the bottom it feels very
lonely so I'm going to drop the s down
to here okay and the S could happen here
could happen here and we just think
about this
I like the layouts to flow from right to
left or right to left so putting it here
will make it feel like that's a little
separate so I think I want to do this
right around let's say right on here so
now I have some issues with this little
space and if I were doing this computer
I would just move this back a little bit
so let's compare now that layout next to
that layout so one has a symmetrical
balance but it allows the layout to
breathe a little bit more and so you
don't feel like you have separate pieces
to look at and that's the trick that's
all it is okay all right let's go on to
the next one oh this is quite nice I'm
not sure I love the justified right rag
left with the justified left rag right
here I like the colors a lot and I like
that you have a big dark area and orange
and a pink area I think there's some
issues here where this looks a little
bit taller than this orange space and
they should just be the same or they
should be different like I said before
if you're in no-man's land with the
space it's not a good thing and you want
to draw contrast contrast is king so
this is a big space this is a lot
smaller that's okay so I would make this
pink line up here even smaller
I shouldn't say pink it's like magenta
right yes okay so let's let's keep going
okay I see like these are variations of
the same layout and you can see now when
you when you have more of the space
activated this is a much better layout
it allows the thing to breathe however
you've taken up this whole space again
so I bet you if you took just type off
played around with this photo like maybe
it's not as tall and maybe it doesn't go
all the way to the edge your lay it's
going to look a lot better already
and then you can work back in this
typography so when when you're stuck
with design you know quite sure why the
layout doesn't work start stripping them
away things as a little trick here let
me hold up this piece of paper thank you
if I was to cut off
a little bit of that image it would
allow the white to kind of move around
it it'll look a lot better okay all
right let's look at the next one I like
the color treatment here I like this do
its own thing you got going on there's
some nice things working on working out
here but I don't love that there's this
negative space and there's these bars
seem very heavy for what they are but I
do like that they're calling emphasis to
those two things the name of the are the
subtitle and the the number what I don't
love is having one word using two
different point sizes I think this is
the interesting it would be much more
interesting if this word 300-point and
that were the same point size I know
that you're trying to fill a space but I
don't think that's necessary or making
the same point size and just scale them
in here okay let's go on oh this is cool
I like this a lot I like that you've cut
off what is essentially a very straight
typeset and treating the mass headed in
this way it's almost not legible but
it's it's it just needs a little help
and that's it
in a layout like this okay I noticed
this thing here you're using the print
registration marks you'd have to use
that pretty heavily throughout so it
doesn't feel random right now it feels
quite random in there if we just take
that off it would be a nice nicer layout
and lastly I think we want to repeat
elements so you have this strong angle
and I think if you were to repeat that
as a graphic element like a line if you
repeat at the same angle a little line
right here and then use the logo right
there I think the I would make that
connection and draw even our
subconscious level it would work it's a
similar one I don't I don't love this
one
I think this is too washed out does he
gone okay there's some things that are
working really well in this layout using
a different font now I think it's din I
loved in beautiful font and I like here
that you're introducing this kind of
over print effect where you're taking
two photos and you're letting them print
right on top of each other I think the
thing that's killing you here is this
large mass head on the side I think if
you take that out imagine that without
it and line it up here
and did it kind of big but here I think
your layout will look much much better
you did a nice job with this I'm not a
fan of centered but I think you did a
good job here so if something you like
centered layout this would be it I think
the way you take this a little bit to
refine it is to repeat some element here
so that it's not just on the left side
okay this one's quite nice I like the
the breaking of the word thirst I like
that that's really bold and up there and
large headline copy and this is quite
nice this treatment here I'm not sure I
love this circular element that's
printed on top I like the effect of it
but maybe this could be a symbol a font
or a word or a letter or a numeral so
that has some meaning that's all I want
it to do otherwise you have to repeat
this so another thing you can do is take
the circle take another circle do it
here and then a little circle here and
it would look really good so let me show
you about proportion there you want to
create small medium and large right so
here's the layout that you have it's
something like this okay right now you
have the circle kind of right here and I
like that maybe you have something like
here like that and then something like
this large medium small small medium
large it'll help to tie it all together
but it's strange to just have one
element there and you could do also sort
of effects it doesn't have to be a solid
color it could be whatever you want I
think that could look really nice okay
let's keep going so you got an angle so
we talked about this before having an
angle randomly thrown in you need to
repeat it somewhere so the way you do
that is you cut off parts of the tee or
you cut up part of the photograph which
could look really good same angle so
that it repeats it's important for you
to use elements that repeat it's like in
music and Composition
you have to have like a beat and it
repeats or a chorus that repeats so it
doesn't sound like noise okay let's keep
going one more okay same thing same
layout essentially right just different
treatment in it okay cool I think you
have one more set but we're going to
take a break right now and you can look
at it in a little bit cool thanks so
much okay this tells me a lot about who
she is in terms of her desire to kind of
figure out
kind of almost every exploration that
she can she's not gonna get stuck with
one expression or one idea and that's a
really good sign for a designer is it
den that's horrible it looks like euro
style yeah yeah I don't like it okay
things like this is good things like
this are good but I need to see a little
bit more so I could read it simplistic
and what interesting approach
interactive so you just need to give me
enough so I can read it okay that's
that's beyond the love of legibility
okay let's keep looking so you're you're
applying shapes and it's dynamic grid
it's fine I like this this could be a
nice layout for something the typography
here is not great I think you're much
better taking the type off that I'm just
leaving a red triangle and breaking the
grid a little bit okay when I look at
this page if this were the page it looks
really good
the only it's not looking good is this
and the font that you're using better
than that it looks good to me let me see
the last page okay so it's that alright
so the number one takeaway on this is
for you to make sure first go back and
look at the things I've already pinned
about newspapers that I like that
there's enough content and density
because I'm not gonna print that many
pages I'd rather have it to be full of
stuff than to spread it out I'm not
trying to do that we're gonna get
submissions from different writers
they're going to talk about their
perspective on business or creative
entrepreneurship and I want to I want
that in here so we want to get a lot of
content in here okay there may be one or
two spreads world where it can be more
expressive but it can't be the bulk of
it when you look at a newspaper I don't
have one here but it's gonna have lots
and lots of things in it it's trying to
get you a lot of information okay let me
look at your other font now and that's
the last thing that we're gonna do you
got a you got to put this together in a
way that I can see it
I know it's convenient for you to design
like that but then I need to see it
spreads yeah I think you didn't make
this view a spreads but I don't want to
deal with that right now okay so here's
what I want you to do I want you to go
back and look at what we looked at in
terms of the newspaper and things that
we like and to make sure you design this
content to reflect the amount of content
we need to have I also don't want you to
explore so much anymore we've done this
exploration thing that I need to get
into really showing me what this
magazines gonna look like from cover to
cover does that make sense so look at
the covers that I liked take into
consideration all the things we've
talked about
today and then go back and do some
spreads match it up with a cover do
whatever things you need to fix and I'm
gonna give you end of day tomorrow
what's the day in debate Thursday you
show me something again all right it's
that cool does that give you enough time
it does are you sure because you can
tell me no this is what we call allowing
the person the designer to say no in
case because they feel intimidated and
they're gonna say yes and then come back
tomorrow at the same time and she's not
it there and she's panicked and stressed
out so you got to give them permission
to say no to you so I'm giving you
permission to say no to me right now do
you have enough time to do what we
talked about perfect thank you very much
man and I'll sneak up behind you one
more time to scare you just for fun
all right guys if you like this kind of
video and you want to see more about
what it is that we're doing here in
terms of design and typography this is a
very specific case in terms of designing
editorial layout now you like to an
editorial layout right not like my other
friend editorial is not your weakness so
you like doing this stuff you have
practice at doing it and if you want to
see more content like this let us know
in the comments below thought you guys
next time